"THE FIVE."
A NEW GALLUP POLL SAYS FOUR IN
TEN AMERICANS EMBRACE SOCIALISM.
WE SHOULD GASP AT THIS.
I'M NOT SURPRISED IT'S NOT
HIGHER.
THE FACT IS, PEOPLE THAT KNOW
WHAT SOCIALISM IS, THOSE THAT
FLED SOCIALIST COUNTRIES,
THEY'RE GETTING OLD.
MANY ARE DYING.
THE KNOWLEDGE OF SUCH HORROR
GOES TO THE GRAVE.
THEY'RE BEING REPLACED BY THE
LOWEST FORM OF LIFE ALLOWED ON
CAMPUS WITHOUT A LEASH.
SOCIALIST PROFESSORS.
THESE GATE KEEPERS KEEP
SOCIALISM FROM BEING UNDERSTOOD
THE WAY SOBER SURVIVORS
REMEMBER.
WHY WOULD A SOCIALIST ADMIT THAT
A GRIME LOSING TEAM KILLED
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN INSTEAD,
THE GHOULS SHIFT EMPHASIS ON
OPPRESSION OF WESTERN
CIVILIZATION.
IT'S WORKING.
WE HAVE SOCIALISTS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE AND THEY'RE WINNING.
THE GREATEST TRICKS THAT THE
DEVIL EVER PULLED WAS CONVINCING
THE WORLD THAT HE DIDN'T EXIST.
THE GREATEST TRICK IS THAT
SOCIALISM DIDN'T HAPPEN.
IT'S NOT LONGER A MURDERIST
IDEOLOGY BUT A CUTE THING THAT
GETS YOU FREE THINGS.
WE WITNESSED ONE HELL OF A
MAKEOVER.
CHARLES MANSON IS NOW SANTA
CLAUS.
SO THERE'S SOMETHING DISTURBING
GOING ON, JESSE.
A NEW QUINNIPIAC POLL THAT DANA
SHARED.
IT'S AN INTERESTING POLL.
>> Jesse: SHE LOVES THE POLES.
>> BIDEN WENT FROM 38 TO 35.
SANDERS JUMPED FROM 11% TO 16%.
SO WE HAVE SANTA CLAUS,
SOCIALISM CLOSING IN AND COULD
BE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> YEAH, I DON'T KNOW IF
BERNIE'S RISE IS REAL.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEA -- SAY ABOUT
THAT.
IT'S BALONEY.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT IT IS.
I WOULD AGREE THAT APPEAL OF
SOCIALISM IS INCREASING FOR TWO
RUNS.
ONE, SOCIAL MEDIA IS LIKE A
RADICAL DEN OF SOCIALISM
IMBREEDING.
IT'S POLITICIANS AND JOURNALISTS
TAKING LIKES FROM POLITICALLY
CORRECTED PLAYMAKERS.
IT RISES EVERYBODY UP UNTIL YOU
HAVE A REALITY THAT IS
COMPLETELY DETACHED FROM THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY.
SOCIALISM IS A RESPONSE FROM
DONALD TRUMP.
THIS WINNER, THIS NATIONALIST.
THEY SAY WE WANT TO PIVOT TO THE
OPPOSITE OF THAT HE HAS THIS
WINNING CAMPAIGN TO MAKE GREAT
AGAIN WHICH WANTS TO
RE-ESTABLISH AMERICA AS THE
NUMBER 1 IN THE WORLD AND NOT
APOLOGIZE FOR IT.
SO THE DEMOCRATS ARE STILL
SEARCHING FOR A SLOGAN.
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO, WHEREAS
DONALD TRUMP IS STILL CONTINUING
AS THE CHANGE CANDIDATE,
DEMOCRATS ARE JUST TRYING TO GO
BACKWARDS AND RE-ESTABLISH THE
OLD ORDER.
THEY DON'T REALIZE THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS CANNIBALIZED 20% OF
THEIR ELECTORAL MAP,20% OF THEIR
POLICIES AND THEY'RE STILL
TRYING TO FIGHT IN THE SOCIALISM
WINDERNESS OUT HERE ON THE LEFT
INSTEAD OF THE CENTER.
>> EMILY, YOU LIKE CHARTS OR
GRAPHS?
>> YES.
>> GREAT.
LET'S GO TO THIS GRAPH.
SURPRISE.
THE YOUNGER YOU ARE, THE MORE
LIKELY YOU WILL EMBRACE
SOCIALISM.
18 TO 34, 58%.
SAY IT'S GOOD.
ONCE YOU GET OVER 35, DROPS TO
40.
I STILL THINK IT'S HIGH AT 36%.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW -- ONCE YOU
GET TO THE NEXT LEVEL, ANYBODY
THAT HAS BEEN ON THIS PLANET
LONG ENOUGH TO EXPERIENCE WHAT
HAPPENS TENDS TO NOT LIKE IT.
MAYBE THIS IS BEING SKEWED BY
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT HAVE HAD IT
TOO GOOD.
>> THERE'S CERTAINLY THAT
POSSIBILITY, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
NAIVETY AND THE PROGRESSIVE
PITCH AND THE SOCIALISM
TENDENCIES BEING PUSHED ON
CAMPUS.
JESSE, I DISAGREE WITH YOU.
>> Jesse: LET'S HEAR IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
IT'S NOT HYPOTHETICAL AT ALL.
I'M FROM THE BAY AREA.
I LIVE IN SEATTLE NOW.
SOCIALISTS HAVE DECLARED WAR ON
THE DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT.
FORGET ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN IN THE PICTURE.
THE SOCIALISTS HAVE TAKEN OVER
THOSE WEST COAST CITIES.
WE SEE IT RAMPANTLY IN MY
OPINION WITH THE HOMELESS
POPULATION AND ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT STEM FROM THAT.
THE PUBLIC POLICY PRINCIPALS,
THE DEPENDENCY PROGRAMS IN
PLACE.
SEATTLE SPENDS A BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR ON THE HOMELESS.
TO WHAT END?
A GROWING POPULATION.
THERE ARE SO MANY STATS AND
QUOTES I CAN BUST OUT.
THE BOTTOM LINE THERE THIS
POLICY FIGHT HAPPENING ON THE
LEFT.
IT FORCES AND CHANGES PEOPLE TO
FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO HAVE THIS
COMPASSION DRIVEN APPROACH.
ALL IT DOES IS UNDERCUT THIS
REASONABLE FIRM HARD LINE THING.
IT IS A MAGNET POLICY FOR
HOMELESS AND FOR OTHER THINGS.
THE REALITY IS, THE WEST COAST
CITIES ARE LIVING SOCIALISM AND
WHY THEY'RE BEING BANKRUPTED AND
TAKEN OVER AND FAILING TO
PROGRESS IN ANY WAY.
>> JUAN, AS A CARD CARING
SOCIALIST, HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT REASONLE ANALYSIS?
>> I'M BATMAN, TOO.
>> LOOK HOW EXCITED SHE IS.
>> YOU LIKE THAT.
>> AS BATMAN, LET ME SPEAK TO
THE JOKER.
BECAUSE YOU SAID OH, TRUMP IS
SUCH A SUCCESSFUL -- YOU MISSED
HAVE MISSED THE IDEA THAT HE
BANKRUPTED --
>> HOW OLD GOLD CLUBS DO YOU
OWN?
>> I DON'T PLAY GOLF.
I DON'T OWN GOLF CLUBS.
>> THE PROBLEM HERE, TRUMP AND
THE REPUBLICANS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE POPULARITY OF SOCIALISM.
YOU KNOW WHY?
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE THEY KEEP SAYING
EVERY GOOD IDEA AND POLICY THAT
THE DEMOCRATS COME UP WITH,
SOCIALISM.
>> NAME ONE.
>> IT'S SOCIALISM.
LET'S TAKE HEALTHCARE.
LET'S DO SOMETHING ABOUT STUDENT
DEBT.
SOCIALISM.
THEN YOU KNOW THAT GRAPH YOU
SHOWED, GREG, ABOUT THE AGES?
HOW INTERESTING THAT SENIORS
THAT GET SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE SAY OH, TERRIBLE THING.
SOCIALISM.
THAT'S A SOCIALIST POLICY.
>> IT'S THEIR MONEY.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
WE PUT MONEY --
>> I PUT A LOT OF MONEY TO
SOCIAL SECURITY.
IT'S NOT COMING BACK.
I'LL NEVER SEE IT AGAIN.
>> IT'S THE YOUNG PEOPLE
PUTTING, PAYING FOR THOSE
POLICIES.
I THINK THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO
SEE SOCIAL SECURITY.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> THAN THE SENIORS.
>> ANOTHER BAD PROGRAM.
>> LOOK AT THE GI BILL.
LOOK AT SO MANY THINGS.
THEY'RE INTENDED TO MEDIATE THE
EXCESSES OF CAPITOLISM WHICH HAS
EMBRACED EVERYTHING FROM CHILD
LABOR, SLAVERY, MONOPOLY --
>> THIS IS 2019.
>> DANA, IF YOU LOOK AT
CAMPUSES, YOU WON'T FIND A
SINGLE SOBER ANALYSIS OF
SOCIALISM.
>> YOU WILL STILL FIND HOWARD
ZEN'S BEST SELLER.
HE SAID CAPITOLISM IS BAD.
I WISH I CAN REMEMBER THE NAME
OF IT IN THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
NAOMI RILEY HAD AN INTERVIEW
WITH A GUY THAT WROTE A COUNTER
BOOK.
I'M GOING TO BRING IT UP IN A
COMMERCIAL BREAK.
SOMEBODY WILL FIND IT.
HE'S A PROFESSOR.
NO, ACTUALLY THIS IS ALL GOOD.
I WONDER ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE,
PART OF IT, IS IT REBELLING
AGAINST PARENTS AND WANTING TO
BE DIFFERENT?
I DO THINK THERE'S THIS NOTION
THAT SCANDINAVIA IS LIKE THE
UTOPIA.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND GO LIVE THERE FOR A
WHILE.
>> AND MOST OF THEIR WEALTH WAS
DUE TO FREE MARKETS AND TRADE
BEFORE THEY ENACTED THE BIG
GOVERNMENTS.
>> Dana: AND ALSO BECAUSE OF
FOSSIL FUEL, OIL AND GAS.
THAT'S HOW THEY FUND THEIR
GOVERNMENTS.
>> A LOT OF THE VICTIMS ARE
CAUSED BY INCOME INEQUALITY.
WE TALK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS.
WHY DO WE HAVE SO MUCH --
>> CAPITOLISM.
AMERICANS --
>> BECAUSE WE HAVE A BOOMING
ECONOMY --
>> LIBERAL MAYORS.
>> THEIR RENTS ARE HIGHER --
>> Jesse: SO THERE'S A BOOMING
ECONOMY.
>> THE ECONOMY IS HOT.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU.
LET'S WRAP THAT UP TO A SOUND
BITE.
>> THANK YOU, PRESIDENT OBAMA.
I KNOW THAT HURT YOU JOKERS.
>> I'M HAPPY.
YOU'RE HAPPY.
LET'S MOVE ON.
>> I HAD A GREAT POINT BUT I'LL
SAVE IT.
>> ONE LAST POINT.
>> THE POINT ABOUT MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
LOOK AT BERNIE SANDERS.
HE'S NUMBER 2 IN THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY HE WOULD
HAVE BEEN NUMBER 1 IF IT WASN'T
RIGGED.
NOW HE'S 20 OR MORE POINTS
BEHIND BIDEN.
WHY?
YOU THINK MEDICARE FOR ALL?
THAT ACTUALLY HAS HURT THE
DEMOCRATS.
SO I DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS
THE WAY THAT THEY WANT TO GO
POLITICALLY.
IF YOU START ASKING ACTUAL
DEMOCRATS DO YOU LIKE THE
HEALTHCARE PLAN THAT YOU HAVE,